[Música]
[Aplausos]
a ver
quiero pasarles este valor y lo mueven
rápidamente entre ustedes eso muy bien
rápidamente exactamente
stop así de rápido como se muestre balón
entre sus manos se mueven las fake news
en los medios digitales antes la
responsabilidad de verificar la
información era casi exclusivamente de
los periodistas cuando estudiaba
comunicación un profesor me habló sobre
el impacto que tendrían las redes
sociales y cómo modificaría en la forma
de hacer periodismo
hoy yo creo que necesitamos tener estos
tres pilares fundamentales que les voy a
dar en este momento yo los llamo la vc
efe verificar contrastar y usar el
sentido común verificamos que la
información que nos está llegando a
nuestros teléfonos es real y está
ocurriendo en este momento contrastamos
contra otros medios digitales o personas
que estén en el lugar de los hechos y
usamos el sentido común es que yo creo
que es más difícil de aplicar
sobre todo si simpatizamos con esa
noticia o facebook que llega a nuestras
manos
quiero que repitan conmigo verificar
contrastar y usar el sentido común
verificar contrastar y usar el sentido
común excelente con estos tres pilares
fundamentales vamos a dejar de ser
repetidores de noticias a ser verdaderos
periodistas ciudadanos
y es que como sociedad le damos el poder
unos pocos cuando realmente no manejamos
la información de forma correcta y eso
es lo que queremos
yo pienso que para un país no hay nada
más importante que una sociedad que se
encuentra empoderada de la información
confirmada muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]